think so you're christian right you
think christians are all up in each
other's business i feel like christian
this is why
there's pros and cons i've done catholic
and i've done christians right
catholics i love yeah every sunday it's
like once a week it's horrible 45
minutes i'm not gonna lie to you guys we
gotta up the service like it's i'm so
bored the whole time yeah um and so for
that reason i prefer christian mass
but but what i liked about catholics is
they just kind of mind their own
business yeah my last christian church i
i started dating a guy right and he
wasn't christian
and i got so many calls from these
people i barely knew i'm like who
could you guys like leave me alone but
they had some good intention though it
was amazing because they realized that
sometimes romantic relationships can
definitely cause an asteroid effect
between your relationship with god
obviously that's what they're
looking at their their logic behind i'm
not saying you need to agree with it but
i'm just saying that's their logic i
don't understand framework they're not
working from i understand that yeah i
get i understood the intention
but i just feel like i'm a grown ass
woman yeah chill
and
i'll get i'll get this i'll get this
advice from my parents and the people
that actually know me
i mean
what i thought what should happen is
that this is what we think is good but i
didn't today it's your choice you're
going to make the decision anyway they
can't police you 24 7. right but they
have to be intellectually honest that
they say i don't think this will be good
for you right spiritually right and but
that's what i like about catholics
though they just kind of they're chill
yeah but they think at the same time
though it's christian
this is the question i posed to you okay
what's the number one
qualm people have were christians
what did they say how were christians um
judgmental
yeah what's the other one just throw it
in there um what's the other one that
they're i'd say judgmental is the
biggest one no hypocritical oh
hypocritically we don't live up to us
our ideals oh yeah yeah
yeah the same way the reason why that
way is because obviously if you're a
christian
it implies that you're going to live
under a certain moral code right yeah so
and there is a thing that says okay if
you're a christian and you claim to
follow christ right and you'll do x y z
right it has to be say okay you're not
following the program right it's a bit
like if i'm in the army right and i
don't follow what my sergeant says well
but i'm like you got you ladies are
single
and so it's like
i don't really see you having better
results so why would i take advice from
you and not my parents yeah and so yeah
but this is what comes down to it is
it's a you say it's a holistic uh
problem right whereby we need to get
more men to church right i agree with
that and it's the same thing as like
then i was like okay do i wanna
there's like okay and the church i was
in there's maybe like two or three guys
that i would consider like i was
attracted because one there's a lot of
beta guys in the church a lot of
feminine guys yeah like i would never
give the time a day i'm sorry yeah um
and then two there's like one or two
guys but like there's like
women lined up for those guys because
they're like one of the few good looking
guys in the church
i don't want to why don't i just date
someone outside of the church yeah but
the problem is that you have the
achilles heel of potentially you know if
it goes serious and
if you're very spiritual and he's not
yeah and you have kids together yeah
it doesn't but i think that's knowing
the guy's character and i think a lot of
guys aren't in the church but would be
fine with like a woman like raising
their kids in the church because i
possibly i'm not saying it wouldn't work
but potentially it's a lot of banana
skin i'm just saying from you know what
it is i feel like i feel like
if if you're a female in a church like
um
and this is me quoting
um i don't know a second joyful joyful
noise right yeah um one of the scenes
was like a guy comes in completely out
of the church and sees one of the
females singing in the joyful noise
right she loves her and whatever i feel
like
if you're a woman of you know belief and
god and stuff like that right
you have a lot to offer yeah and if a
guy like necessarily don't necessarily
like a guy from church like he said yeah
but a guy outside of church right he
meets you and you fall in love with him
right out of just the pure blinds for
like you saying you will still as a
woman who have more to offer because you
went to church like nicely but you know
what i mean yeah and then the guy
would obviously treat you like as a
princess and whatever like right we'll
get together
but obviously
it would be like a like a respectable
boundaries between that that's why
but my argument with that would be that
can work but i've just i'm saying it
from a statistical perspective and
you've definitely you've been good at
this yeah that's more the exception than
the rule most times if those relations
do happen it does affect
the christian woman and she'll be like
why did i marry this guy
for love
here's like what i disagree with though
like the numbers just don't add up to
what you're saying there are not enough
men in the church so so i think what
you're saying is like idealistic
ideally sure like of course but like it
when there's not enough men what else
are the girls supposed to do
so
yeah
just because i have a it's like me
saying
oh there's a problem with um
um
let's say racism in our society so the
solution is joint black class matter so
you know i mean yeah there are nuanced
discussions with it as well so what is
your thingy of like you know um
building on that thingy you said like oh
black lives matter
but you remember the there was like a
little segment and this is coming from
like five minutes of fame type segment
yeah all lives matter yeah i feel like
that's [ __ ] i think it's a bit like
saying i i've created a
a charity for cancer but someone says
but also aids yeah yeah yeah yeah
i think it's i think it's yes i think
it's said in a i uh and to be fair
initially i would have taken all lives
matter but to someone actually explained
use the ideology so
like if you put it if you put it to
perspective of like
if someone comes up on the screen right
we've never heard this before and he
goes oh lives matter yeah oh life's not
just to begin with right
i feel like we just had a smooth ride
yeah whereas he said black lives matter
right
right yeah
and then he goes on like not necessarily
him but like another person goes but
then at the end of the day all lives
matter
that's like that's a bit like sometimes
you can be like it's a bit like you know
like i said i start charity but i said
what about
yeah you can't you can't slay every
dragon you can only slay one dragon at a
time so
okay guys there's another super chat
thank you thank you thank you raw gynema
may i'm sorry i'm so sorry i know can i
call you raw
oh no just call him rob
okay um let's go the thing i love about
hos
is they never truly change just present
their situation and risks and their
mindset the bad boy can always oh hose
the thing i love about hoes is that they
never truly change just present their
situation and risks and their mindset
the bad boy can always get it
never change ladies us
fellas only need time to get you
oh yeah
i think they're saying hoes don't change
like a once a whole always what you
think about that
one's
[Music]
has the um
that that does do what we call love
legs open very easy okay legs legs open
very easy i'll agree to that legs open
very easy okay okay now two yeah once a
hoe always a hoe yes or no okay have you
heard of the term what a proverb means